[Background Music]
Waiberg: What attracts me in armchairs
Is that they always include a story.
Some have been made 100 years ago,
My life has become better with work
In the manufacture of these chairs.
When I was 25 years old,
I discovered that I had a disease in my eyes.
It has been 30 years now,
I have a vision of 5 degrees,
It will continue to fall until it is gone.
The most important thing is that I feel the material in my hand
I feel right.
Everything is in your hands,
You can feel something before seeing it.
I see that reviving the chairs again looks like
Give someone another life to live.
What makes me feel great
I am actually making something that makes a difference
For others.
[Background Music]